do you believe that the demonstrations
tomorrow will be as big
as last sunday or maybe even bigger
you know nobody can guess but
i'm sure people will go out and will go
out as much
as necessary because um
they're not ready to be with these
authorities anymore
they will not forget they will not
forgive what has happened and they uh
so is they're sure and we are sure that
uh their elections were falsified and
but how worried are you that maybe the
momentum
could be going down that you could be
losing momentum
you know i believe in our people and i'm
sure that
we will not lose this moment anyway even
if
we there this movement will
slow down or come down a little bit but
our people uh
they will not accept our president
anymore we have changed
our minds have changed and we will not
be able to
be under this president anymore under
this authorities we will struggle
till our victory till
we will get the changes in our country
how wide are you that tomorrow we'll see
new violence
that the security forces will again use
violence against protesters to try to
stop them
um you know our authorities saw that
they vali
the violence they had during those two
days
uh didn't calm down people
it just made them angry
and they understood that they made a
great mistake
and i'm sure that
they will not do this mistake anymore
because
they understood that this didn't stop
people
it just made them give them more
strength more you know more reason to
have to to struggle
more and more do you have a message
for the military for the police
about what they should do if they do
receive
orders to fire and fight at their own
people do you have a message for them
sure i have we all always during all
this election campaign we
call for not to fulfill
this order to show it or just to go
against
peaceful people because we and you
i mean police and usual people we are
one nation
and the russians can't beat the russians
just you and we are
just you know we are the same you can't
go
against your mothers your sisters and
your brothers you don't you don't have
to do this
but i understand is the order and it's
the decision of
every military he fulfills this order
or he stays with his nations he stays
a human and don't go against
harmless peaceful people
you said yesterday at your press
conference that you have not received
contact from
vladimir putin and why not contact him
yourself
he's such a key figure in in this whole
story
maybe i will write down a message for
him i
know i don't know yet would you be
willing to meet with lukashenka and have
dialogue
directly with him
if it is the necessity of it and i will
understand that
it's necessary so why not